hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner koch
wales heute gibt es wieder ein sehr
leckeres rezept und zwar mache ich heute
nudeln und zwar tag die stelle mit einer
la sauce und die luxus ist bei uns was
ganz besonderes paket nämlich eine
richtig süßes geschichte dahinter ob die
erzählerische es gleich ich zeige euch
jetzt nämlich erstmal die zutaten
ich habe es heute eine große portion
wenn ihr aber nur drei bis vier personen
zeit nehmt einfach davon die hälfte
ich brauche lachsfilet das war jetzt
tief gefroren
ihr könnt auch frisches lachsfilet
nehmen ich habs jetzt nicht genommen
weil ich keine lust hatte die gräten zu
entfernen und es sind etwa 750 gramm
zwei esslöffel mehl 3 4 esslöffel
olivenöl 2 zwiebeln 2 knoblauchzehen die
dürfen natürlich nie fehlen
hier habe ich eine bio zitrone damit ich
gleich die schale verwenden kann und den
saft 400 g schlagsahne 450 bis 500
milliliter gemüsebrühe
ihr könnt aber auch fisch vornehmen und
meine tag der teile das sind etwa 600
750 kommen und zuerst nehmt ihr euch
jetzt die zwiebeln und die
knoblauchzehen und die werden jetzt fein
gehackt in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal den
hört ihr anschalten und die pfanne
erhitzen
morath jetzt darfst du erzähle wie
sodass lachs gericht bei uns sowie von
das ist ein bisschen hochdeutsch reden
kann schwegler
ich wollte ein bisschen aufrufen und
habe dann natürlich für zehn personen
habe ich dann dax zeichnet er in japan
ist es war das erste und letzte mal
sicherlich gekocht
alles was mit bereitung welcher ganz gut
an die muskatnuss genommen hat
damit kam es gegen 1 ist ja gar nicht da
rainha und ich habe den fisch
vorgearbeitet
telex erreicht da hat mich rumgekriegt
genau ist sowas dreckig dass ich nie
wieder koch und doch was jetzt steht der
kamera und ich vor der kamera passt
alles aber das gericht habe ich von ihm
das rezept nur dass er in fischform
nutzt hat die panische zeichen hier gebe
ich jetzt meinen olivenöl rein und auch
direkt die zwiebelwürfel und die werden
jetzt bei mittlerer hitze so ein
bisschen glasig gedünstet und begriffe
die hört man immer und liest man in
kochbüchern
aber das ist einfach so ein bisschen
weich gedünstet und die werden an so ein
bisschen durchsichtig und
in der zeit kann ich aber schon x mal
schneiden und den schneide ich jetzt in
etwa 1 cm große würfel
das geht ganz gut weil ich mir aufgebaut
habe
dann gebe ich da die fisch würfel mir
dazu
genau wie ein bisschen hoch schalten
damit es schön an dreht
es ist schon richtig lecker maske
und wenn der fisch ein rundum angebraten
ist gebe ich jetzt das mehl dazu erzählt
sein gleich dass die soße etwas dicker
wird und eben bindet und sobald es mail
dann untergerührt ist und so ein
bisschen angebrachten ist könnt ihr den
fisch mit der gemüsebrühe ablöschen
und dann gebe ich da jetzt noch die
zitronenschale mit das so und ich finde
gehört unbedingt mit rein weil zitrone
erst suche zum fisch passt und die soße
da nicht so sehr nach sahne schmeckt ein
bisschen frisch nach zitrone das macht
einfach nach eigenem geschmack
ich mag es gern etwas toni auf und gibt
es wegen die komplette schale mehta zu
und damit so ein bisschen säuerlich
jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft mit rein
da erstmal nur die hälfte und wenn ich
später abschnitt hier kann ich immer
noch was dazu geben und ich lass das
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen kuscheln
so etwa fünf minuten bis etwas von der
gemüsebrühe aufgezogen ist und
verdunstet ist und dann werde ich das
lose fertigstellen und in der
zwischenzeit koche ich schon mal wenn du
so was raus und dann kam auch gleich
ganz pendelt die soße ist schön
reduziert und ich koche es hier auch
bereits meine nudeln und jetzt gebe ich
noch die sahne zu der soße dazu und ihr
müsst es auch immer so machen dass die
soße bereits fertig ist und die nudeln
daneben kommen hat sie die nudeln dürfen
nicht auf die soße waffen sondern die
soßen auf die nudeln
jetzt hält sich die soße noch mal ein
bisschen und ich hab mir grad dazu
entschlossen nicht die komplette seine
reihen zu geben
ich gebe es nur etwa 300 milliliter
reihen das reicht auf jeden fall
und ich würde das jetzt noch ein
bisschen mit pfeffer und chili
und etwas oregano etwas war gut von
esslöffel und ich geb dir jetzt auch
noch mal ein bisschen zitronensaft mit
dazu weil die säure jetzt schon ziemlich
weg ist ich habe damals eine mit rein
gegeben hatte sie als neutralisiert und
jetzt ist die soße einfach nur ein
bisschen fertig köcheln nicht mehr zu
lange damit sie nicht gerinnt
die nudeln sind auch gleich fertig und
dann können wir es gleich schon
servieren jetzt kann das essen schon
serviert werden hier die leckeren nudeln
kann mannschaftsteile machen
menschen moralisch mich abgelenkt mit
nudel eine minute früher raus nehmen
ich bin aber al dente besser wenn sie
noch so bisher bis 14
und es ist eine funktion
dann von der leckeren soßen
noch ein basilikum blatt und ich mag das
auch immer ganz gern wenn ich so frische
kräuter mit drin hab ich habe hinten
einen kräutergarten und der wächst
übrigens immer nach wenn ihr die blätter
abschneidet und man sollte sie aber auch
so ein bisschen umsetzen weil die sind
immer so dicht gepflanzt und wenn ihr
das machen hatte immer frische kräuter
zu hause
und dann ist die leckere lachs nudel
kartelle fertig das rezept gibt es
natürlich zum nachlesen auf cds -
blog.de und ich freue mich schon darauf
wenn ihr das mal nachmachen mir fotos
sendet und wie sieht es dann einfach
beim nächsten mal wieder für gold